What do you think of methylene blue, methylene blue? Well, it's better than
silent green. Sorry. Okay, methylene blue is, so I think this person is asking what
do you think about off-label use of methylene blue? So methylene blue is
is used really to treat a disease that has to do with the hemoglobin's ability to carry oxygen.
And it's, there's a specific disease. I think it's a metham, the themoglobemia or something
like that where the person can't carry oxygen, methylene blue at its dosage. That's what it was
approved for. Now, using it off-label at, using it off-label at the full dosage can be a problem
for some people because it increases the hemoglobin's ability to carry oxygen, but also a side-effect
of it increases serotonin levels in the brain. So methylene blue I know is really pushed by Dr.
Mercola. Now he's using it at lower dose, I believe. So it's an off-label use of methylene blue because
it increases oxygenation to the tissues, he thinks it increases, you know, and I believe it probably
does increase the mitochondria's ability to get oxygen there by increasing your ability to make ATP.
So you will have more energy, it can help with things like that. The problem is, is if you have
a defect in the genes in the biopter and pathway, you may make too much serotonin, you may have
these what are called serotonin surges with it, which can't be very dangerous. You can have serotonin
surges with people with defects in the biopter and pathway, even by taking methyl groups. So a lot
of people are taking methyl tetrahedral folate, or methylcobolabine in high doses because they have
an MTHFR gene defect. So they think they need to take high doses of methyl folate or they've been told
by their naturopaths very incorrectly that they should be taking, in the U of MTHFR defects,
you should be taking high doses of methyl folate. It's the same thing with methylene blue. If you're
going to take high doses, if you're going to take methylene blue, it's going to produce a methyl group.
Problem with that, methylene blue as a compound does increase oxygenation, but it also gives off a
methyl group, which could be a tumor suppressor blocker. So two bad things about methylene blue
with cancer patients. Number one, it can increase serotonin with anybody, even if you're not a
cancer patient, in the brain. Well, what's the bad thing about increase serotonin in the brain? I
thought increase serotonin was a happy gene. It's a happy neuro transmitter, and it makes you happy.
No, excess serotonin makes you range, makes you angry.
Excess serotonin can turn you into a crazy bully fighter, and you go off the handle and
the smallest little discharge. Matter of fact, it's believed that many people that are mass
murderers and people that have issues with the school shootings and things. One of the ideas
for a genetic standpoint is they have defects in their biopter and pathway, and if they do get too
many methyl groups, it can cause this range output. So that's bad for anybody. The bad thing for
cancer patients is that it increases methyl donor groups, which can turn off tuber suppressor genes.
So while it is the craze, methylene blue, is kind of a new craze in alternative spectrum to help
with people with really low energy, maybe even depression, can't seem to, you know, chronic fatigue
issues. And I have no problem with trying to use it for that reason, but you got to go slow
because you can cause other issues. So methylene blue is used to increase oxygenation of the tissues.
Therefore, alternative practitioners has said, let's use it a little low doses, and we can help people
with chronic fatigue. But you have to look at the biopter and pathway genes. If you do have gene
defects in the biopter and pathway, you can create excess serotonin levels, which can be deadly
at high levels, and at medium high levels will cause range issues. And that's the serious condition.
I remember having a patient years ago where she just did a genetic review, and I was talking to her
on the phone about her genetics, and she had a lot of defects in the biopter and pathways,
and she was taking methyl groups from another practitioner, was telling her to take methyl tetrahedral
folate. And I said, I can pretty much tell you what your personality trait is. And her inner
husband or other photo, I said, I bet you have times where you just lose your temper and you scream at
your kids, and then you go in the bedroom and you cry and you go, what in the world is wrong with me?
Because that's what happens when your serotonin levels bounce way high in the brain.
And you have these episodes of elevated serotonin in the brain. She started crying in the phone.
Well, I never made that same mistake with a patient again, because her husband then said,
well, just this morning, she threw a plate at the wall and put a hole in the sheet rock.
And because you can literally look at a person genetics with the bioptered pathway, and if they're
on the wrong supplements, that could be very dangerous. So methylene blue is a methyl donor,
and that can cause those issues. You have to be careful with that. So you have to be careful with
off-label use of drugs. And you have to be careful with use of nutritional supplements as well,
just because somebody's pushing them for something does not mean that they're good for you,
number one, and it does not mean they're good for cancer patients in general, number two.
And it doesn't mean that these people that are pushing these things are looking at the big picture,
number three. I know with the, with the onset of Instagram and everybody trying to be a nutritional
hero out there and gain as many followers as possible, they're posting a lot of stuff that are a lot of
kind of untruths. And these people are, you know, maybe they're not doctors, maybe they're not
looking at the total physiology. Maybe they're just trying to gain followers. You just have to be careful
out there. That's all I'm saying. Just be careful. That's why I look at your supplements that I take
you guys off some stuff. Because most of the time, a lot of people start with us and they're on,
a lot of mental groups, they're on copper, which stimulates cancer growth. They're on things that
stimulate growth of cancer in general with cancer patients. And they shouldn't be doing that. And
there are, and I've had people come back to me and say, I talked to my natural breath and
he, she can't figure out why you took me off this because I have this defect. Well,
they're not looking at the big picture. I don't want to insult anybody's intelligence. And I'm not
always right by any stretch of the imagination. And I'll gladly be proven wrong on anything.
But I just want you to know by a period I spent way too much time in this question.